in 2001 the state of gujarat swore in a
new chief minister
his name was narendra modi and he's now
the prime minister of india possibly the
country's strongest leader in a
generation evidence was very clear that
poverty had declined very sharply during
mr modi's tenure in gujarat this was of
course the result of a number of
initiatives that he had taken economy
wide
but his rise didn't come without
problems
in 2002 over the course of three days
deadly riots by hindus targeting muslims
spread across gujarat
according to official figures over 1 000
people were killed
223 people reported missing
and another 2 500 were injured
[Music]
everybody attacked us even the police
they poured kerosene and acid on us and
set us on fire
a narrative has been sought to be spun
trying to paint prime minister modi and
the bjp in negative light critics say
that the buck stopped with him the local
law enforcement was his responsibility
and he let things go out of hand but the
supreme court has absorbed him of all
charges
but the violence in gujarat was not an
isolated incident that only happened
under modi's leadership it's one of many
religiously charged riots over the years
mainly targeting india's muslim minority
which makes up roughly 14 of the
nation's population
[Applause]
and it continues to this day
whether it is riots where it has
involved muslims or hindus or sikhs or
anybody else
the denunciation is extremely explicit
by prime minister modi and by the bjp
but some leaders of the bharatiya
janitor party or bjp have also
explicitly promoted india as a hindu
nation rather than a secular one
critics accuse them of emphasizing
identity issues while turning a blind
eye to increasingly bolder hindu groups
all these things emboldened the hindu
nationalists the fringe elements and
they're the ones who undertake
large scale writing and
lynching
the popularity of modi has given allied
politicians the courage to enact new
laws around the country that explicitly
discriminate against muslims
most of whom don't support the bjp
i strongly feel that the government is
sending the message that muslims do not
belong to this country
now some observers warned that the bjp
led government may seek to exploit
religious divisions to consolidate power
at the expense of india's minorities
the fear
it has created among the community is is
actually the main monster which is
driving the people to suicide to
depression almost everyone is affected
although tensions between indian hindus
and muslims existed for centuries they
more or less lived and worked side by
side if you go back and read the history
i mean the divisions were there but they
were not explicit or they were not cause
for any friction amongst the population
but the british raj had a strategy that
firmly separated them into groups it was
called divide and rule how do you
control this mass of population you
divide them along religious lines the
caste lines
policies including a separate electorate
for muslims led to rigid religious
identities this also allowed the british
to pit groups against each other and
consolidate their own power it was
essentially to continue ruling over this
large population and large land mass
and an area which
was really uh
pretty productive rich and helped the
british empire back home august 15th
1947 the great symbol of the british
empire came down for the last time to be
replaced by the banner of the new indian
government
but in 1947 when great britain decided
it could no longer afford to be in india
it decided to partition the subcontinent
into two independent dominions pakistan
which also included modern-day
bangladesh was designated as a muslim
majority area and india was designated
as hindu
the result was an unprecedented
migration of 15 million people which
historians say claimed between half a
million and two million lives in the
bloodshed that followed i guess
the contours of that agreement was
possibly the biggest
tragedy in
india's history because it led to the
largest migration of population and it
was pretty violent and bloody so
thousands and thousands of people lost
their lives hindus who moved from
pakistan into india and muslims who
opted for pakistan as their homeland in
1947.
the violent nature of the partition
created an atmosphere of hostility and
suspicion between india and pakistan
that still exists
it also influences the relationship
between india's hindu majority and
members of its muslim minority who
didn't flee to pakistan during the
partition
it's very difficult for
certain set of people to forget that
event you know the hindus accuse muslims
of doing it muslims accused hindus of
doing it so i mean those divisions have
continued
till this day
but there were attempts by early leaders
to reverse this trend
when india became independent the
leading congress party that included
india's founding fathers jawaharlal
nehru and mahatma gandhi wanted a
secular country
they had envisioned a secular state
where everyone is treated equally
irrespective of caste creed religion
gender others disagreed
gandhi was assassinated in 1948 by a
former member of rashtriya
swayamseveksang or rss a secretive
all-male society founded in 1925 that
promotes india as a hindu nation
they are one of the biggest
organizations in terms of sheer numbers
i mean i would say they're present in
almost every district if not every
village in india
a young teenager named narendra modi was
a member of rss but later shifted to the
bjp which is inspired by rss ideology as
a political organizer the way the rss
works is that rss loans or lends one of
its
key members or leaders to the
political party they generally have a
fair idea of the political lay of the
land so they guide the bharatiya janta
party in the sense
modi moved rapidly through the bjp
hierarchy in his home state of gujarat
and became the state's chief minister in
2001. according to my research gujarat
had done the best actually among all the
large states of india you know when he
became chief minister gujarat was ranked
sixth by per capita gdp by 2006 gujarat
was already number three
but a year after becoming chief minister
the deadly religious riots occurred
gujarat chief minister narendra modi has
now given out an interview in which he
has said he has done absolutely the
right thing in 2002 when the state was
hit by riots
i am an industrial nationalist
i am a patriotic nothing is wrong
i am a born hindu
nothing is wrong so i am a hindu
nationalist so you can say yes i am
indonesia list
modi led gujarat for 13 years before
turning to national politics running
against a congress party increasingly
seen as corrupt and ineffective by
citizens at that time it certainly
looked like the congress-led coalition
government was not very likely to return
but the issue of course was whether bjp
could emerge as an alternative and that
required decisive leadership that is
when the then chief minister
modi
decided to enter the fray modi
capitalized on his image as a strong
leader to win the election
he made bold promises that appealed to
the masses including bringing toilets to
all rural areas and bank accounts to all
i was a little sort of taken aback that
is he going to be able to do it but
successfully he did it there was one
week in which he opened so many bank
accounts that
it got into the guinness book of records
despite some unpopular and highly
criticized economic decisions other
major reforms remain popular among
average indians whether they're hindu
nationalists or not
they want a very strong leader they want
faster growth they want somebody who
takes quick decisions a government
that's nimble
the covert 19 triggered an economic
slowdown as it did in most places and
that required a non-economic strategy to
consolidate power
modi and his closest aide amit shah
pursued a strategy of uniting voters by
stressing a hindu identity instead of
one divided by castes
an idea that could unite all the caspase
voters creating a new majority that
rules india for decades to come
modi's even bigger re-election victory
in 2019 showed his ability to appeal to
the masses
we are a party and we are a government
for every indian and the constitution
grants every indian irrespective of
religion equal rights
after modi's re-election the government
scrapped seven decades of autonomy for
the contested region of kashmir the only
part of india with a muslim majority
the state of jammu and kashmir was the
only article in the indian constitution
which had the word temporary in front of
it every political party including the
congress including others have
repeatedly
said in parliament and are on the record
saying that this temporary condition
should go and it took prime minister
modi and the bjp to have the political
will to make that happen and over in
assam his ally political leaders are
introducing new reforms that seemingly
single out the large population of
muslims that live there
they
were brought to assam from today's
bangladesh by british colonizers to work
in the agricultural field to grow more
food
there was a section who do not welcome
these people
for them they thought that this is a
threat to their language and culture
they persuaded the colonial
administration that there should be a
demarcated area
and this muslim pigeon settled either in
river island or in river bank areas
when the partition happened they didn't
go back to pakistan because
they were already integrated to the
society
they felt that this is their land
and they were also very much with the
indian nationalist movement which is
very secular under the leadership of
mata magandhi
johal nehru
assam which is led by the bjp compiled
the final list of the national register
of citizens or nrc in 2019 by verifying
people's documents the act aims to
separate genuine citizens from illegal
immigrants proving citizenship is
difficult for two reasons one is there
are many people those who do not have
proper documents
and the number two is
these documents are not appreciated
[Music]
the nrc a key feature of the bjp's
election manifesto threatens to render
1.9 million people stateless overnight
most of whom are muslim
although the nrc has affected other
indian minorities as well as some hindus
non-muslims have recently been given a
path to citizenship
it's called the citizenship amendment
act and it was passed by parliament in
december 2019. it prioritizes
citizenship for undocumented hindus
sikhs buddhists jains parties and
christians from the neighboring muslim
majority countries of afghanistan
bangladesh and pakistan the government
describes these groups as persecuted
minorities
india has an obligation has a moral
obligation and a legal obligation to
provide shelter to the minorities of
these newly created nations
because their original homeland was
india
critics point out that persecuted muslim
minorities don't qualify for citizenship
under this act
if they are coming to india
if they are not muslim
then the government will give them
citizenship
but if that person is
muslim
then that option is not available under
this new citizenship amendment act so
this is a clear violation of
indian constitution indian constitution
is a secular constitution
the nrc along with the citizenship
amendment act has only fueled concerns
that modi's party is using the measure
to advance a hardline hindu agenda
hello
to deal with the people rendered
stateless by the new laws modi has begun
the construction of camps
with the largest one in assam which will
be able to hold three thousand people
found to be foreigners by the new
registry law
so far five other facilities have been
constructed with a push to build more
as a detention campaigner
foreign
to make matters worse the climate crisis
has caused some rivers to rise in recent
years making many of the muslims who
have inhabited those areas for
generations homeless
money
[Music]
bang
when they get displaced
normally government has to provide them
compensation
but because of the societal and
political divide these people they are
not getting any kind of compensation or
rehabilitation from the government
now this government saying that you are
illegal and closer
and
these muslims in a large number they
have been evicted from their home
but events in assam seem to reflect a
nationwide trend
hindu nationalists are building a temple
in iodia on the site of a mosque
destroyed by hindu activists in 1992 an
event that triggered deadly riots and
remained sensitive for muslims
that was a mosque and the court has
accepted that the demolition was illegal
but the same court has given the land to
construct a temple
modi laid the first brick on august 5th
2020.
there have also been reports of
vigilante mobs attacking people
transporting cows which many devout
hindus consider sacred
and new laws prohibit the consumption of
beef
what i feel is that this actually gives
some sort of license to the vigilante
groups to carry out the crime like
lynching we have already come across
cases
where muslim men are harassed
because of caring beef
and the chief minister of uttar pradesh
yogi adityanath led a campaign that
accused muslim youths of seducing hindu
women to convert them to islam this law
prohibits inter-religion marriage
between hindus and muslims especially
hindu women marrying muslim men
these marriages are now made illegal
and the allegation is dead
this muslim men marry hindu women to
convert them to islam this is ridiculous
at least one marriage was ordered to be
annulled by a court
but support for the hindu nationalism
cause is far from uniform across india's
hindu majority after the citizenship
amendment act was passed protesters of
all faiths took to the streets across
the country
that gave actually some sort of hope
that
there are
people in the society from the hindu
community who are against this brutal
violation of indian constitution
other critics also include some of the
country's most influential billionaires
as well as the indian diaspora in
silicon valley
freedom house a us-based advocacy group
said that among the world's major
democracies india suffered the steepest
declines in civil and political
liberties in recent years
there has been some sort of resistance
and resilience among the community as
well there are people within the
community those who are
supporting the victims especially those
who are facing this problem of
citizenship contestation we also see
that people
within the community they have started
speaking out about these issues
so i think
along with this we have some sort of
positive story as well
although modi remains popular india's
democracy still allows for citizens to
voice their opinions and make a
difference
the backlash the government faced after
caa led to them developing cold feet and
they have kept the national register for
citizens or national citizenship
register on the back burner
the chief ministers of several states
said they would not implement the
citizenship amendment act and nearly 2
000 academics and professionals signed a
statement condemning the law for
violating the spirit of the constitution
while modi still remains popular the
negative reactions to the new
restrictions seem to have given his
government pause
there are numbers of religious
minorities who are facing terrible
assault and attacks and rapes and
murders and genocide who continue to
seek shelter in india so there is a
demand
that we must do something about them
give them shelter but as far as the caa
act that you're referring to which was
passed in parliament two years ago
some people have already started getting
the benefit of citizenship and those who
are eligible that is till 2014
who have come across as refugees will
get it
into
foreign
foreign